well as you can probably guess from the  title Wild West online is an MMO based  in the Wild West from what we could tell  is very driven by loot finding treasure  panning for gold hitting rocks for gold  and protecting your gold until you get  back to town where you redeem your gold  for cash getting cash is one of the main  goals because if you die and you have  gold on you bandits have the opportunity  to steal that gold but oddly enough they  can't steal your cash as you can tell  from the footage it's a pretty rough  build there are very few NPCs but the  game promises to have a lot more whether  cooperative NPCs or adversarial ones  I mean we're expecting a mix the  developer hasn't made promises as to  like how many you're gonna see if you  enjoyed early looks like these give us a  like and subscribe to our channel if you  have any strong thoughts about this game  share in the comments below thanks for  watching  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  you  you  you